very good morning to you are watching
the breakfast show here on Sky News one
or two problems with our Ultra Q this
morning I'm sure we'll sort it out very
shortly indeed want to bring you the
very latest on what is happening in
Turkey as we are hearing that hundreds
of people have lost their lives in
Turkey meantime back here in the UK then
we have got the biggest strike of the
NHS history the very latest on that
coming up in just a moment it's Monday
the 6th of February
the very latest from Turkey where there
is an earthquake that we're just hearing
about hundreds of people have lost their
lives
the earthquake was felt across here in
the Middle East and this morning part of
an office shops and bad weather are
hampering the rescue effort
these are the latest pictures reaching
us here are from Southeast turkey and
Alistair will be with us throughout the
morning to bring you the latest
thank you
and for the first time in NHS history
nurses and ambulance service on strike
on the same day
I'm outside St Mary's Hospital in London
where patients are told to still call
999 in an emergency but routine care
will be badly affected
foreign
everybody we love a challenge on a
Monday morning don't we uh let's bring
you the very latest on what we're
hearing from hundreds of people who have
been killed by an earthquake in uh
turkey and also in Syria 7.8 magnitude
Quake hit early this morning toppling
buildings and triggering a search for
survivors in some areas whole
neighborhoods are reported to have
collapsed
turkey has declared a state of emergency
and requested International Help
hundreds of buildings have been
destroyed by the earthquake and rescue
workers are searching through piles of
collapsed concrete and Twisted Metal
let's get the latest from Ali who's
standing by for us in the region
um good morning to you Alistair what's
the latest Where You Are
good morning Kay well we've been on air
for about two hours reporting the latest
developments and in that short time the
death toll has risen threefold and I
think there is no doubt it will climb
dramatically the pictures coming out of
Southern turkey and Northwest Syria are
devastating the rush is now on to try
and see if they can recover any victims
who have been buried under the rubble
but it will need a huge International
difference is my report on the latest as
first light has dawned over the region
[Music]
[Applause]
the earthquake struck a few hours before
Dawn as most people are still asleep
his first light broke across Southern
turkey the sheer scale of the damage
became evident
the death toll started to rise rapidly
and the coming hours will be an urgent
rush to find survivors under the rubble
the earthquake was powerful and shallow
only six miles beneath the surface and
it was felt around the Middle East
some of the worst reports of Devastation
are coming out of Northwest Syria where
many of the buildings are already
damaged from 12 Years of Civil War and
there are hundreds of thousands of
refugees
turkey has declared a state of emergency
and already requested international
support Aid will start arriving from
around the world but getting into
rebel-held parts of Syria will be a
challenge in itself major aftershocks
have followed the initial earthquake
including one recorded at 6.7 on the
Richter scale
the next few hours are certain to reveal
more tragedy as the rescue effort gets
underway
ouster bunkel Sky News
so as you can see from the pictures
there and they're emerging sort of every
few minutes out of Southern turkey and
Northwest Syria the devastation looks
extreme and it looks widespread The
Rescuers in turkey has a history of
earthquakes so there will be a degree of
expertise already on the ground in
Turkey they have to go gently they will
have to make sure that they don't
displace any major blocks of concrete
from the collapsed buildings and they
will do everything they can do to try
and find anyone who is trapped under the
rubble because as I said in my report it
happened uh just before Dawn many people
who have been asleep in their beds and
I'm afraid that probably will add to the
death toll coupled with that you've got
very bad weather particularly in
Northwest Syria it's cold rain reports
of snow as well that is not going to
help matters and then you know it's the
issue of simply trying to get Aid into
these places turkey will have its own
own the Diplomatic problems or issues
when trying to accept International Aid
although I'm sure they will do northwest
Syria is all together more difficult
because of the situation there it is
contested territory has been for more
than a decade it's War ravaged many of
the buildings already in a very very
poor condition and you've got hundreds
of thousands of refugees there is an aid
Hub in Dubai which is obviously not far
away in the region Warehouse is stuffed
full of humanitarian Aid things like
medicine food shelters and specialist
equipment that will be ready to go but
they will need to try and negotiate
access in there and they will need to do
it as a matter of urgency because in
situations like this it is no
exaggeration to say that every minute
counts and particularly the first few
hours after an earthquake like this they
try and find anybody who is still alive
buried under the rubble
yeah 360 is the latest death child that
we are hearing isn't it but we're also
hearing uh that the United States is
immediately stepping up and offering Aid
to the country that takes time to get
there though doesn't it
yeah it does take time although a lot of
these organizations and Charities who
have the expertise to deal with
earthquakes or other humanitarian
disasters are on a very short notice to
move anyway and we'll try and move in
there and often our help as quick as
possible it's not easy to reach
um that part of the world even at the
best of times
um but as I said there is that Aid Hub
in Dubai that is strategically placed in
that sort of Crossroads of the middles
Crossroads of the world really with
their airport connections and if they
can bring that into play then that will
help a great deal turkey of course is a
NATO Ally a member of NATO
um so there will be connections that
they might be able to draw on there when
dealing with some of their allies but
Northeast Syria is a whole different
ball game
um and try to get people into that
country and be able to work there in
safe 50 will not be straightforward the
white helmets the civil defense and
rescue Force that operates in Northwest
Syria is already very skilled uh
unfortunately over years having to deal
with things like air strikes and
artillery strikes buildings
um so they are on the ground but they
will need as much help as they can get
yeah just looking um at Twitter just hit
seeing president zielinski has just been
tweeting I extend my condolences to the
president erdogan the people of turkey
and the families of those who lost their
lives in the earthquake in and wish a
speedy recovery to all the injured we
stand with the people in this difficult
time we are ready to provide the
necessary assistance to overcome the
consequences of This Disaster that's the
latest that we're hearing
um from president zielinski and I'm sure
other leaders other world leaders will
begin to Rally around very quickly um
Aleister
sure um as people start to wake up
across Europe and then into North
America the help will start coming in or
at least offers of help will start
coming in
um you can't uh fail to be shocked by
the pictures that you're seeing and I'm
sure that turkey's allies will want to
do everything they possibly can do to
offer any support and that might be
needed for that turkey as I was saying
has because of where it sits has a
history of earthquakes and um you know
it's not a good thing it was to compare
one to the other but the last worst uh
the last earthquake they had major
earthquake they had was in 1999 when 17
000 people lost their lives
um the death toll in this is nowhere
near that yet but it is climbing rapidly
and I'm sure it will raise questions
within turkey again uh in the aftermath
of this
building standards housing standards and
whether or not a lot of the
infrastructure particularly in southern
turkey which is a slightly poorer Area
country whether or not they are built
sufficient standard to withstand uh
earthquakes and the history and the
vulnerability turkey has to suffering
natural disasters like this yeah and and
you were saying um Syria I'm just
looking at pictures as we're chatting to
Syria um some parts of Syria badly
impacted as well do we know the latest
situation then the potential death toll
so the news coming out of Syria just by
fact of um the situation there is coming
out more slowly than it is in turkey and
we're getting fewer pictures from Syria
but the pictures that we are seeing and
the news that we are hearing is very
similar to what uh you can see now in
turkey and that is buildings that have
been completely flattened as I was
saying a lot of them have already been
damaged structurally from years of
fighting
um so that means that they would have
been considerably weakened you've got
hundreds of thousands of refugees uh who
already living in miserable conditions
that will be affected by this uh the
white helmets the rescue service there
have described this as major disaster
I've heard of hospitals either too
damaged to accept victims or too
overwhelmed to accept any more and my
gut feeling is that as the morning wears
on and more news comes out of Syria it
will only grow worse and it will start
to look incredibly Grim there indeed so
I'm just looking at the latest figures
via the Reuters news agency telling us
um that um at least 500 people turkey
and Syria have so far lost their lives
as a result of this earthquake in the
early hours of the morning for those
just tuning Our Way Alistair tell us
what we know
so an earthquake uh the magnitude of 7.8
on the Richter Scale struck uh Southern
turkey near the city of gazian tap you
can see it there on the map
um in the hours before Dawn this morning
it was shallow
um six miles beneath the earth's surface
which would have made it uh more
destructive
um that earthquake was felt around the
Middle East reports of people feeding it
in Lebanon and in Cyprus some reports as
well in Gaza although I've spoken to our
colleagues over there and they didn't
feel anything we didn't feel anything
here we should say but the damage is
located very much in turkey and in Syria
as you can see from the pictures there
major aftershocks as well not helping
matters one Aftershock was recorded at
6.7 magnitude which in and of itself is
a powerful earthquake bad weather
conditions in some parts of that region
are all also a factor as well some areas
experiencing snow at the moment and as
you can see from the video coming in
some buildings complete patterns sort of
Pancakes downwards and are just now
piles of rubble underneath which there
will be people trapped
some of them dead but hopefully some
still alive that the rescue workers will
be able to get to and try and pull to
safely
yeah we're talking about Aid and as you
said it's in the region already from
countries like the United States and the
UK for just such a an eventuality given
that we do see earthquakes in this part
of the world but I'm seeing that gazian
airport has now been suspended for all
civilian flights and looking at some
images of hate airport in southern
turkey it's been literally torn open as
though a zip has gone down through the
center of the runway there'll be no
planes um Landing there as I said the
latest we are hearing is more than 500
people having lost their lives you were
saying that the weather particularly bad
there at the moment I was hearing on the
radio on the way in that people are
running out into the streets in the
early hours just at dawn when this
earthquake hit um it's freezing cold
it's snowing and they run out with just
what they were standing up in
yeah there's a there's a cold front
coming across the Middle East at the
moment which would bring some very bad
weather and that not only makes the
rescue efforts that much harder to carry
out but of course makes the people who
are being already displaced whether it's
by conflict in Syria or um in the case
of the pattern their homes have been
destroyed and that makes the challenge
facing them uh ever more concerning and
Aid has been pleasure as I said but
there is a um
diplomatic negotiation that will need to
go on before it comes in
there are many expertise around the
world particularly in Britain there's an
awful lot of Charities and organizations
who are very very skilled in working in
situation situations like this and they
will bring in specialist equipment from
listening devices to using sniffer dogs
as well and going into the rubble and
sniff out the location of bodies or
listen out for anyone who might be able
to make a sound underneath that Rubble
in the desperate hope that they can be
located so around the world those kind
of teams will be scrambling now and
offering up their help in order to try
and get access into the region but you
know there's a lot at the moment against
them we've spoken about whether we've
spoken about conflict but as you were
saying hey there some of the damage to
the airports uh in and around there look
I think they'll look to utilize whatever
airports would be whether it's civilian
or whether it's military
um one of the keys in this kind of
situation is when a lot of Aid is
flooding in to make sure that you have
some sort of intelligent coordinated
effort to distribute it and to make sure
it gets to the right places it's all
very well having tons and tons of Aid
Landing in
cargo planes on the runway at an airport
but you need to make sure that there is
the right kind of expertise to get it
out and across the region as road is
most needed yeah I mean looking at these
pictures Alistair looks like a war zone
doesn't it
um absolutely
um devastated many of these buildings
hundreds of buildings were told have
collapsed after that earthquake at dawn
in Turkey this morning heavy lifting
gear will be moved in and they have to
do that very sensitively they don't they
because these buildings are very
precarious now we're going to be
speaking to a rescue engineer in just a
few moments time but
um looking at some of the images on on
Twitter as well many of which we can't
show to our viewers at this stage this
is where the challenge Begins for these
rescue workers
yeah and a lot of it will be literally
lifting stuff by hand moving Rubble Away
by hand which which might sound as
though it's a very unsophisticated but
as you were saying with with major it
there's a danger here as well for the
rescue workers this will be these
buildings will be very very unstable
um they will be very mindful of not
shifting anything that would cause
goodness to collapse even further or
further some of those major concrete
blocks to Crunch down uh not just for
the people who are buried underneath but
also for The Rescuers there
um who have to go very very carefully
and that does mean that
um and we've seen some of the pictures
that were broadcasting bulldozers which
can take away some of the rubble but a
lot of it will have to be done by hand
and whilst it is a rush Against Time uh
to try and locate people at the same
time you have to take it very delicately
and very carefully as you go through
this bit by bit and this is just one
building we're looking at there are
hundreds probably thousands of buildings
like this across that part of the region
it'll be in a similar State and uh so
that is the difficulty that faces the
rescue workers I'm just reading now as
well and tweet from someone in the
Israeli foreign Ministry saying the
thoughts of Israel with attacking its
people as we see the first pictures of
the horrific results of the earthquake
so okay as you as you said the um the
messages are coming in from from leaders
and from governments from around the
world uh who will offer and pledge their
support and arrays and that will will be
needed in the coming hours and it'll be
a case of trying to find the right way
and the best way to get it in okay
um take a breather Alistair back with
you in just a second Maria Caulfield
Minister for women
um under Secretary of State Department
of Health High um all sorts for us to
talk about but let's talk about turkey
what are we going to do to your home
well obviously it's a tragic events that
have unfolded um overnight and we'll be
offering um assistance required and
working with other countries too uh to
give the insistence that they need so I
I know that cabinet colleagues will be
looking at this first thing this morning
okay what do you know about it so far
well we just know that there's obviously
been an earthquake and there's been a
number of people who've been killed and
are missing and help is going into to
finding uh what support turkey needs at
this time
um inducer we're hearing that many
hundreds of people have sadly lost their
lives we are blessed in this country
with not really being particularly
impacted by earthquakes this area though
very much is a lot of the properties are
not really up to the challenges that you
would expect to withstand an earthquake
we know that some of the runways for
airports have been devastated
it's going to be tricky to help what do
we do immediately well it will be tricky
to help but I think if you look at the
help we've given other countries in
similar situations in the past we're
quite experienced in terms of getting
into places where say airports are down
and where access is difficult and we've
got a number of means of access in terms
of whether that's flying in support or
whether in the longer term getting
support in by sea as well but the first
priority is to make contact with turkey
which is being done to ask them what
help they need and to get them the
resources that will support them over
the coming hours and days okay that will
have of course involve Medics which
brings me on to what's happening here at
home today Nurses and ambulance worker
striking again they say that they have
heard absolutely nothing from Rishi
sunak or Steve Barclay how to resolve
this onpass well I'd slightly disagree
with them that they haven't been meeting
with the Secretary of State during
January he held almost weekly meetings
with a range I I mean I take a point on
pay before Christmas that was not
necessarily on the gender but since
Christmas absolutely pay and working
conditions have been on the agenda we're
very keen to talk about forthcoming
years pay award in terms of us
submitting evidence as a government and
the unions submitting theirs and the
slight disappointment is we're in
exactly the same place as Scotland in
wanting to talk about the forthcoming
pay award the RCN have suspended strikes
in Scotland but not in England and what
I would say to Pat Cullen who I respect
very much and the RCN is if you if
they've suspended strikes in Scotland to
discuss the forthcoming pay award
um uh please could they suspend them in
England so we can get around the table
negotiate have a chance than England not
in Scotland so in Scotland they're just
at the negotiation stage about the
foreign
Scotland they uh put to the RCN members
in Scotland I think about 7.58 payoff
for that was rejected by the RCN members
in Scotland and that's why the strikes
were ongoing they have since the spend
did those on talks on the the new pay
award for this forthcoming year we ask
that the same happens in England because
every day a strike action happens it
does impact on patients nurses have
suggested or certainly nursing leaders
have suggested if they're offered an
extra three percent on top of what
they've been offered now that they would
look at that which is exactly what
they've been offered in Wales so they've
been offered that in Wales it's not a
full three percent increase they've been
offered 1.5 increase and a 1.5 lump sum
which would not be carried over in in
subsequent years
um that has to be put to members yet so
we don't know if the members in Wales
nurses expect that well we have been
pretty clear that we're not going to to
look at the current Year's pay award
that was agreed in April by the unions
and by the government and accepted the
pay recommendation in full we really
want to focus on the forthcoming pay
award as they're doing in Scotland and
record that which will recognize a
number of issues such as inflation
um you know uh Recruitment and Retention
that that's factored into the pay review
bodies recommendations England's nurses
being offered less than those in
Scotland and Wales they're not being
offered less than in Scotland so
Scotland's at the negotiations those in
Wales well we have to take a responsible
uh view about everyone's uh uh so are
they being irresponsible in Wales I'm
not you know I'm not going to comment on
the negotiations in Wales they haven't
been agreed by RCN members it's been put
to the members and will know the result
of that in the forthcoming days members
May well reject that in Wales as they
did with an eight percent uh pay rise in
Scotland what I can say is that we are
we've got a responsibility to all
taxpayers in this country and we've got
a range of public sector workers asking
for pay increases and every one percent
increase is about 700 million pounds
that we have to find uh to pay for that
and obviously we've got covered backlogs
we've got patients waiting for routine
procedures we've got uh one of the
busiest Winters we've ever had with
record levels of funding going into the
NHS to try and manage services so um
every percent of a pay increase takes
money away do you think that NHS workers
are putting lives at risk going on
strike I think it's a it's a challenge
you know obviously I'm I'm a nurse and
I've you know got I I am asking you yeah
so I campaigned where there's a pay cap
and a pay freeze um when we had the lib
Dem coalition government so I'm for you
know I know how difficult it is to live
on a nurse's wage but also with ongoing
strikes it's not my question though with
respect do you think that NHS workers by
going on strike are putting lives
there's a risk to patients the longer
strikes go on so if you're cancel for
your operation the first time there's
probably a minimal risk that's canceled
time and time again because of ongoing
strikes then patients become more poorly
and there's always a risk and with
ambulance strikes you know if someone's
not um got to if they're having a heart
attack or a stroke you know that does
increase someone's risk the longer that
response time is for being a nurse is a
vocation isn't it so um putting
someone's life at risk is completely
counter to what you go into nursing for
well I don't think any nurses going on
strike wanting to put patients at risk
and I know that it's been a very hard
decision for the majority of nurses and
that's why I say to Pat as the RCN have
done in Scotland we're very happy to
discuss the pay award for the
forthcoming year suspend the strikes
let's get back around the table and see
if we can resolve this for patience as
much as for staff okay it doesn't like
it though does it anytime soon well you
know the door is open Secretary of
State's door is open and we would
welcome the RCN in particular uh coming
around the table they have withdrawn
from the Independent pay review uh body
process which is not independent that's
why well I would disagree because
there's been times where we've not
accepted the independent pay review
bodies recommendations and Years Gone by
and so if it wasn't independent that
would not be the case we did accept it
in full um this year and the unions did
as well and you know that's the our
method of getting a pay settlement for
the forthcoming year we need to curtail
our interview today I'm sorry because of
other events but thank you very much
indeed thank you thank you that's uh uh
wander down to Saint Mary's Hospital
should we uh in London Melena is on the
picket line there this morning
um hi I wonder what they would make of
what we hear from the health Minister
this morning good morning to you
good morning well the picket line just
getting started here but this strike is
expected to be more disruptive than
previous ones because more Hospital
trusts are involved if you have a
life-threatening emergency 999 will
still come to you do ring it but
anything else that may be an emergency
you may that you may not get a response
similarly with Hospital appointments
they many many will be canceled and many
many elective surgeries now elective
surgery are very broad term it's things
like hip replacement and hernia surgery
those are things that really impact on
people's quality of life but the nurses
here say they've been simply forced into
this position by a decade of low pay
that they say is driving thousands of
nurses out of the profession 25 000 of
their colleagues they say left nursing
just in the last year this is creating a
huge Staffing shortage that is having an
impact on patient care now they have
appealed directly to Rishi suno to take
the reins of this negotiation because
they say they haven't made a lot of
Headway with Steve Barkley at all they
say how come in Wales there's been an
agreement there's no strikes there
they've been suspended how come in
Scotland and negotiations are ongoing
why can't Westminster do the same and as
this dispute continues to escalate it is
the patients who are suffering that NHS
waiting list already nearly 7 million
people on it only set to become even
longer
okay for now thanks very much indeed
obviously updating you on that story uh
throughout the morning here on Sky News
but when I return to the breaking news
you're waking up to this morning a major
earthquake in turkey and Syria has
killed at least
560 people and flattened whole
neighborhoods
the 7.8 magnitude earthquake hit just
before four o'clock in the morning local
time with several strong aftershocks in
the following hours
Tremors were felt as far away as Cairo
the death tone in turkey and Syria Syria
expected to rise still further
these are the live images
um that Alistair is with us again now
Alistair this is exactly what you were
predicting uh delicately moving Brick by
Brick as they try to reach those that
are trapped beneath the rubble as these
buildings pancaked down at four o'clock
this morning
yeah and it's that that pancaking is
described of buildings it is is often
the most delicate
um what most destructive in terms of
casualties with the most delicate uh to
deal with for the rescue operation and I
think you're saying there are a mixture
between official
Rescuers fire and rescue service for
example paramedics but also clearly
volunteers
um survivors of the earthquake local
residents who are there I'm sure family
members and Friends uh trying to find
their relatives amongst the rubble
they'll have to go very delicately it is
a precarious situation it is not being
helped by a number of other factors
aftershocks which are always the case of
major earthquakes I've seen reports
somewhere of them being in excess of 40
aftershocks already uh in the last few
hours including one that was measured at
6.7 on the Richter Scale which is
a pretty severe earthquake in and of
itself another factor that isn't helping
matters and you can see it's in some of
the clothing that people are wearing
there is the weather
um it looks uh to be reasonably dry from
those pictures but elsewhere around your
affected region particularly in Syria it
is bad weather including some cases of
snow that will not just have an impact
on the rescue effort but it will also
severely and potentially dangerously
impacts people who will have been
displaced because their homes have been
destroyed and there are really multiple
challenges facing turkey and Syria now I
mean the first and the most obvious is
the search and rescue efforts that will
at some point turn to a search and
Recovery effort also treating those who
have been wounded
more straightforward in somewhere like
turkey which has
um sophisticated hospitals less so in
Syria which has been the casualty of
more than a decade of Civil War and I've
heard reports
this morning of hospitals now either
destroyed themselves and so therefore
unable to function
or just too overwhelmed to take any more
casualties in and then as I was saying
you have the other factor of displaced
people people who no longer have homes
to live in because they have been
destroyed where do you put them how do
you house them in some warmth and safety
so those are all the sort of challenges
that will face the rescue teams that's
why International Aid will be essential
in this because of the expertise that it
brings turkey's got a history of
earthquakes given that it sits on a few
major fault lines and so they will have
the experience and expertise there but I
think looking at the damage that's been
caused they will have to call on some
International Help Now um turkey the
government in Anchor her um which is a
functioning government will be able to
do that and we'll be able to coordinate
the response in a far more sophisticated
manner than I think will be the case
over the Border in Syria where even just
negotiating access for Aid agencies will
be a challenge in and of itself and so
the death toll already into the hundreds
and climbing rather rapidly I'm afraid I
just don't think that we are
um you know seeing yet uh anywhere close
to the true extent of what the reality
probably is and I I have seen modeling
online and it's probably not I think
it's probably too much in the Realms of
speculation at the moment to uh to say
publicly but modeling online being done
by experts that is predicting this death
toll to be very very high indeed
looking at um reports um not yet
independently confirmed but certainly
looking at the images of the Guardian
castle built more than 2 200 years ago
so it has seen an earthquake or two in
its time and it appears to have been
completely destroyed by this earthquake
we'll get an update um on that of course
and bring that to our viewers just as
soon as we can within the last few
moments we've been hearing from the
health Minister Maria Caulfield and this
is what she told us about what the Brits
will do
if you look at the help we've given
other countries in similar situations in
the past we're quite experienced in
terms of getting into places where say
airports are down and where access is
difficult and we've got a number of
means of access in terms of whether
that's flying in support or whether in
the longer term getting support in uh by
sea as well but the first uh priority is
to make contact with turkey which is
being done to ask them what help they
need and to get them the resources that
will support them over the coming hours
and days
spring and Mark scorer should we hello
to you mark thanks for taking the time
to join us this morning it's
heartbreaking isn't it when you see see
um Rescuers picking through the rubble
to try to save people trapped beneath
buildings
um the death toll is going into the
hundreds
um you have worked on this sort of event
before Mark where do you start
good morning yes uh firstly I'd like to
say our thoughts are with all those
affected by the disaster and it really
is a terrible time for this to happen
and our thoughts are with everybody
affected
um where do you start that's a very good
question uh initially there turkey has a
has a vast array of very well trained
teams that will be mobilizing
immediately to coordinate these search
and rescue uh actions that you see on
the screen there uh it will then expand
from there to reach out to the
International Community as they've done
so already identifying the resources
that they may need
yeah I mean looking at the images as I'm
chatting to you it looks like a war zone
it's difficult to get in help is it aid
from around the world when we see that
at least um was hearing that Gathering
airport certainly has been suspended for
civilian flights but hate airport has
been completely destroyed by the looks
of it
yeah obviously the the infrastructure to
allow teams to mobilize and get in
country uh May well have been damaged
but but the International Community is
well trained for things like this
there'll be various options and and
situation scenarios that they'll be
running through to work out the best and
quickest ways to get their teams into
country whether it be Overland or by air
at a local airport and and more
transport on from there
yeah
um
aftershocks are always a problem we've
heard of quite a few of them already and
that continues for days does it
yeah certainly days even weeks uh it's
something that the search teams have to
be aware of that they train what to do
in an Aftershock if they're deep within
a collapse structure if there are safer
areas than others so it's certainly a
risk of additional collapse of buildings
and something everybody on the ground
needs to be aware of unfortunately now
as far as turkey is concerned it's no
stranger to earthquakes it sits on quite
a few fault lines
um can a country like turkey ever be
prepared though for this sort of level
magnitude of disaster
uh yes I know uh there's always more
things that you can do and as I
mentioned they've got a very well
prepared teams and a network from from
local up to government level constantly
training readying the local community as
best they can to what they would do in a
response as you can see lots of locals
helping there whether they can be
ultimately prepared to ensure that no
buildings collapse and there's there's
never any loss of life I don't know
about that that's we're not there yet
but it's something that we have to work
towards and hope for in the future we
see citizens getting involved people who
so I felt what was happening at around
about four o'clock local time this
morning ran out into the streets with
what they were standing up in and then
want to do what they can to help do they
help or hinder in a circumstance like
this
uh I think I think they're always there
to help it's hard to stop people helping
when it's their neighbors their friends
and families they can certainly be a
valuable source of information when The
Rescuers turn up to a rescue site
because they they may have been there
they may have heard things and so so I
would say that they are a valuable
source of Intel for The Rescuers and as
you can see there they can help
handballing in safer areas the rubble
from to clear some of the areas
um so yeah I'd say generally it's a
they're a positive influence on the
rescue situation and often it's the the
locals in remote areas that are able to
pull those that are that are lightly
trapped under a building out more easily
and more readily than having to wait for
some of the rescue teams timing is every
everything isn't it it is a Race Against
Time when something like this happens
how quickly does the rest of the world
need to mobilize together
timing is is a key issue as you
mentioned and there's already a request
for assistant that's gone out uh to to
the International Community those teams
that have been on standby already are
very quick to mobilize can can often be
there depending on their location within
within 12 to 24 hours and then it's this
first
three to seven days really that is
critical
um for finding uh life under the rubble
okay thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you just want to bring
you um the latest from our own foreign
secretary uh James cleverley tragic loss
of life in turkey and Syria earthquake
our condolences go to the families of
those who died our thoughts are with the
survivors the UK stands ready to provide
assistance that's the latest from our
own foreign secretary and also we have
been hearing from president zielinski of
Ukraine of course he has been tweeting
as well this morning I extend my
condolences to the president erdogan the
people of turkey and the families of
those who lost their lives in the
earthquake in turkey and wishes speedy
recovery to all of the injured we stand
with the people of turkey in this
difficult time we are ready to provide
the necessary assistance to overcome the
consequences of the disaster we've also
been here hearing from the White House
this morning who have echoed what we've
been hearing from the other two leaders
telling the people of turkey and Syria
that they stand with them at this
incredibly difficult time and will be
there to help and support them as
quickly as is possible the latest we're
hearing that after an earthquake at
about four o'clock this morning in the
region local time buildings began to
collapse the earthquake between six and
eight miles deep registering 7.8 on the
scale and we are hearing that hundreds
of people have died in that earthquake I
think it's fair to predict that that
death toll will only continue to rise
given the images that we are looking at
at the moment bearing in mind also that
it is absolutely freezing cold in that
region at the moment as you can see from
these images the snow once again
beginning to fall our thoughts with the
people of turkey and Syria will continue
to update you here on Sky News
one other major story this morning the
biggest day of strikes in NHS history as
nurses and ambulance workers walk out on
the same day for the first time let's
get more on today's historic NHS strike
action from Mike padum the managing
director of Saint Cecilia's Care Group
and chair of the independent Care Group
hello to you thank you for joining us on
the program
um how worried are you about days like
today
well it's another worry for us okay
because uh social care is in its own
crisis at the minute with massive staff
shortages but we will get through these
next few days um but yes it's a concern
we've got some contingency plans in
place but we're just uh hoping for the
best we get through it with any without
any serious incidents what is the
current situation in um Care Homes
across the country looking at the number
of vacancies that are available
something like 165
000 last year 10 of the workforce that's
alarming
oh it is it is certainly we want the
government to address that issue as well
but I I guess we're on today really with
the ambulance rights and the nurses
strikes is we are finding a tough anyway
in Social care but we will get through
today and we've got the plans in place
we've got no shortage of advice on what
to do but basically
um we will Common Sense will come into
play if we can't get access to Emergency
Services uh for category one or two
calls him then we will actually address
matters ourselves if necessary by taking
uh anyone that's uh seriously ill at
hospitals if there's too much of a delay
so we've got plans in place but let's
hope it doesn't come to that what do you
do
if someone needs to go to hospital today
well um obviously it's category one so
my understanding is that 999 would still
operate but our view is that if there's
a long delay and we think that patients
life is at risk then we would have to
take matters into our own hands and if
necessary and I'm talking about the
worst case scenario we would make sure
that we got that Resident Hospital
directly ourselves uh and we will seek
advice over the telephone on what to do
if that happens but we're hoping as I
understand it I'm a reassured that
country in one still will be answered is
category two and beyond that we may not
got attention for
um if you had the opportunity to speak
to the government we know that they do
watch the program at Downing Street
property station this morning
well I would Echo what's been said many
times before
um get around the negotiating table
because if there is going to be extra
money which I'm led to believe might
come in the budget uh in a few weeks
time is why not put that money on the
table now because lives are at risk
certainly but I would also ask and to
take this opportunity to sort the crisis
out on social Care at the same time
um we are willing to help get around the
table we need to talks and um
and the NHS and social care is in a
massive crisis but no one in government
seems to be taking notice of the
president so I would ask them to get
around the table and come see for
themselves in the front line just what
it's really like
okay thank you for joining us on the
program this morning thank you
um biggest strike in the NHS in its
history let's bring in Saffron Cody the
deputy chief executive of NHS providers
hello to you thanks for joining us on
the program what impact will today's
strike action have
I think it's going to be a hugely
disrupted day across the NHS this can be
incredibly challenging because I think
with both nurses and ambulance staff out
on strike today and nurses again
tomorrow and we've got physiotherapists
later in the week and then some
ambulance staff again on Friday and
we're planning for an incredibly
disruptive week and I think what we've
previously had with industrial action
has been for example Community stuff
Community nursing staff being able to
plug the gaps left when ambulance staff
were out on strike but obviously with
with nurses and ambulances out today
that's going to be incredibly difficult
and what we have to remember with this
is that at this time trust leaders will
be focusing entirely on making sure that
they are keeping patients safe that they
are looking after their staff but what
that means is that they have to step
away from the day-to-day a tasks of the
hospital the business as usual if you
like so they won't be focusing on
getting those waiting lists down or or
putting into place the new emergence
urgent and emergency care plan that's
come out they will be focusing simply on
getting through the next couple of days
and that will have a knock-on effect on
patients
yeah when you say
um a big impact on NHS today can you
give me an example of what we're talking
about
so what we are talking about is an an
NHS service which will be providing
emergency care and emergency support
only so we will be seeing of course
emergency departments will be open
providing that care when people are in
extreme crisis but what what they won't
be getting through is any kind of
backlog recovery so if people are
phoning up for usual appointments if
they are seeking to gain ongoing care
they won't have access to that and also
and I think this is a really important
point to remember this isn't just about
the here and now it's about the knock-on
effect what does it mean when someone
has a procedure a test an operation
delayed for a number of days a number of
weeks you know that will have an impact
on them and the other thing that we're
worried about is people who don't come
forward for treatment because they think
that the weight will be too long they're
in a crisis in an emergency and they
choose not to die on 999 or access 111
because of
um their sense that that service won't
be there for them we're particularly
worried about those people and we urge
anyone in an emergency or crisis to make
sure that they do try to access the care
that they need because we saw that
during the pandemic that people chose
not to go into a e departments for
example and we know that some people
should have come forward for care
um we are hearing that cancer treatments
are being impacted we were told that
that would not happen how can it be
possibly be allowed to happen
so the the situation that that trust
leaders are in is that they will
negotiate what are called derogations or
exemptions from the strike action with
with their local
um Union representatives and I think
that what we are seeing here is a
situation where we have different
Arrangements in place in different parts
of the country and it's possible that
some types of Cancer Care will will come
into into that so they won't be that
Cancer Care won't be Exempted from
from the strike action it's it's a very
challenging situation and it's
particularly challenging for staff when
when they are dealing with that that
particular situation
yeah
um how's this going to end
well I hope it ends by um the government
coming round the table to negotiate a
settlement for this year's pay for
um NHS staff
um that's how it needs to end and I
think that we need to recognize that NHS
staff have faced soaring costs cost of
living has gone up inflation has gone up
and the settlement from last year's or
this year is pay review body
um was made at a time when inflation
wasn't at the levels it it's at at the
moment so I think it's really important
that we focus on getting a deal for this
year as well as them thinking about what
next year's pay deal looks like
okay
um thank you very much for taking the
time to join us thank you back to Turkey
in just a second just want to bring news
about a story that a lot of you are
asking me about actually the head
teacher of one of Britain's most
prestigious schools at Epsom college has
been found dead on the school's grounds
alongside her husband and their
seven-year-old daughter Emma Patterson
her husband George and her daughter
Letty were discovered in the early hours
of Sunday morning an investigation is
being carried out to establish the
circumstances surrounding their deaths
police have said at this stage they are
confident that this is an isolated
incident with no third party involvement
and the story leading many of the
newspapers this morning are private
underwater rescue team set to join the
search for missing mum of two Nicola
bully today new images have been
released from the family's home security
CCTV of Nicola the day that she went
missing
returning though to the news out of
turkey and Syria hundreds and hundreds
of people have died after an earthquake
um 7.8 it measured
um hit both countries around about four
o'clock local time this morning hundreds
of buildings have collapsed and the
buildings are continuing to collapse as
a series of aftershocks hit the region
Alistair standing by for us um Aleister
what more do we know
okay that video that we're seeing now
that internal CCTV of what looks packed
like a bar or some sort of shop it goes
on for about a minute and a half
so that gives you some idea of how long
the earthquake lasted it was a powerful
earthquake as well 7.8 magnitude and it
was quite close to the Earth's surface
around six miles underground and so all
of those facts combined have made this
into a major disaster for turkey and for
Syria the death toll which is rising
rapidly
and well into the hundreds now is
certainly going to rise considerably
modeling I have seen is from experts is
putting the potential death toll well
into the thousands and what is happening
now on the ground as you can see is an
effort by emergency services and by
local civilians to try and clear some of
the rubble from some of the collapsed
buildings and to locate anyone who might
be trapped underneath
wider a field there is an international
effort that is mobilizing with
offers of support coming from around the
world both from governments but also
from the private sector because there is
an awful lot of expertise particularly
in the UK but elsewhere in Europe that
can be deployed at short notice into
situations like this with specialist
equipment to try and locate anybody who
might still be live underneath or to
retrieve the bodies that will have died
as a result of collapsing buildings in
this earthquake so a major disaster to
hit the Middle East it's felt around the
region but the damage focused around the
epicenter not far from the Turkish town
of gazien tap in southeast turkey and
across the border in Northwest Syria a
country and a part of that country that
has already been devastated by years of
Civil War building that are partially
collapsed or destroyed because of the
fighting
many many thousands of people already
displaced because of that conflict and
now they are facing this
um yeah we've heard from president
zielinski who's offering support we've
heard from our own foreign secretary
here in the United Kingdom James
cleverley who's tweeted within the last
few moments
um talking about the tragic loss of life
and saying the UK stands ready to
provide assistance what sort of
assistance from what you're saying there
do they need and these things need to
happen quickly but of course we've seen
the damage to the infrastructure haven't
we already
assistance needs to happen as soon as it
is feasible to do so so they will want
to get teams and Aid into the country as
quick as possible but what you do not
want to do is suddenly flood a disaster
Zone like this with Manpower and Aid
with no sense of centralized
coordination because there'll be
multiple locations multiple towns
villages in order to focus on and is no
good having an airport that is stuffed
full of cargo planes and pallets full of
Aid with no strategy or thought behind
it and so that is where the
International Community will have to
work closely with the Turkish government
um it's again I keep saying it is harder
when it comes to Syria because it is
contested area up there the the regime
down in Damascus have very little
control over what happens up in
Northwest Syria and so trying to
coordinate matters there will be even
more complicated and then you factor in
conditions on the ground to airports
that are partially destroyed runways
that have been split open by the
earthquake these are all problems that
can be navigated around but they must be
done so through a process and not just a
case of everybody rushing to a country
to try and help when things are as
delicate as they are yeah um and
thinking about the the region that we're
talking about and and something you've
just hinted out there I mean turkey
hosting what 3.6 million Syrian refugees
and the area where many hundreds of
thousands of those are uh where they've
been displaced to
um are very close to the epicenter of
this earthquake
it is I mean gaziantep is one of the
major towns just on the Turkish side of
the border so it is um something that
was a refugee crossing road has been in
in years past uh and turkey has been a
sort of a Holding Center for a lot of
Syrian refugees millions of Syrian
refugees that have fled the country fled
the fighting
um turkey has received an awful lot of
international particularly European
money in order to sustain
um that for the past few years and there
will now be even more people displaced
because everybody you see is either an
apartment block or someone's home and
they can no longer inhabit it and so
they will need places to go and stay and
so that is another facet of this this
rescue operation that will need to be
considered there is a major Aid Hub not
far away in Dubai warehouses stuff full
of equipment and Aid that can be brought
into play very quickly if necessary but
as I say these things don't always
happen at the click of a finger there
are behind the scenes diplomatic and
political considerations to take into
account
um so it is it is always going to be a
balance of getting there and getting Aid
there as quick as possible whilst also
making sure it is done in the right and
proper way okay for now um come back to
you in just a second Alistair thanks so
much indeed if you're just tuning Our
Way looking at these live pictures from
Turkey as Rescuers start to pick through
the rubble to try to rescue those that
have been trapped as building after
building collapsed four o'clock this
morning an earthquake measuring 7.8 on
the scale
um hit the region for at least 90
seconds we started by saying 30 people
had died then 50 then 100 then 200 then
300 then 400. and the latest figures are
moving towards 500 people having died
looking at the images of the collapsed
buildings uh that death toll is going to
increase still further
[Music]